social media is changing our minds  social media acts like a drug my guest  today is Max Fisher Max is a writer for  the New York Times and he's the author  of a brand new vitally important book  called the chaos machine eighty percent  of Americans are taking a drug 15 times  a day without realizing it's a drug it's  a referendum on all of the damage  currently being wrought by social media  social media has much more power to  affect how you think and how you feel  than you might believe I've become  increasingly convinced that the impact  of social media and Technology on our  lives and the lives of our children is  truly one of the great existential  issues of our time just spending time on  it you inevitably end up not just  serving the platform when you're online  but in your offline life your emotional  balance changes  [Music]